si l'une de ses villas à côté de chez
vous venez voir mon spectacle norman sur
scène que je continue en tournée dans
plein de pays et la vidéo qui suit un
best-of d'un live qu'on a fait à
quelques jours sur ma chaîne youtube à
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
si vous qui fait évidemment et si vous
avez des suggestions n'hésitez pas à
commenter
j'en tiendrai évidemment content pour le
prochain est très coûteux aujourd'hui
très très bien est-ce qu en régie
l'ambiance est aussi bonne que ça plate
est très bonne on peut faire un coucou
au public aux six mois puis avec le
temps en fait à des vidéos etc
commencent à être apprendre la maturité
on en est fiers un petit peu de nos
vidéos un petit peu engagés on commence
à voir la vie artistique un peu mur oui
oui pourquoi récemment on a été dans un
classement tous les deux parmi les
humoristes préférés des français d'après
mickey magazine
voilà d'avril un journal de mickey oui
je les mêmes matches et les puissants et
bien moi je vais totalement acheter je
le découvre désolé on est quand même en
couverture ah oui en tout lien oui à
côté de pikachu ce week end à damas et
pikachu
moi je me suis renseigné j'ai prospecté
htg magazine j'étais monga jeté dans la
rue à dubaï comme ça j'ai retrouvé une
vidéo qui était pas très dur à trouver
puisque totalement en ligne de votre
premier featuring way
j'aimerais qu'on le diffuse s'il vous
plaît emmerdes j'ai trouvé cette vidéo
est ce que vous voyez déjà merde je me
rends compte que mon visage n'a pas
changé j'ai vraiment un visage toujours
de puces ou bien seulement les cheveux
hirsutes et toi tu avais à la barre
depuis l'âge de 5 ans oui jury la barge
kinect de la barre est assez mal et pas
souci et n'a pas changé
non plus non plus il a vraiment changé
d'habits d'autres contrats roi toi
c'était notre une collaboration musicale
qu'il usait qui s'appelait les bébés
dans le congélateur
exactement sans cette vidéo ça on est
vraiment si tu veux partisans de bon
goût quoi alors je voulais simplement
faire à gagner un cadeau grâce à toi
d'accord ce que tu veux te donner du
plaisir aux gens
ah ouais c'est parti devinez le handicap
de cyprien hockey et il me up astigmate
hypermétropes ou impuissants voilà vous
réfléchissez un cadeau finale qui est
une sorte de téléviseurs hd avait pensé
que sont la caisse
ok d'accord une télé une une caisse qui
regrette pas c'était un truc s'est
dessinée oui j'ai ramené du petit matos
d'accord c'est riou andrade sorte de
feuille
ah oui d'accord j'ai eu un petit dessin
tu coules j'ai pas eu d'inspecteur les
couacs hommes comme comme des saints toi
tu veux qu'on dessine tôt enfin moi tu
veux pas alors qui d'autre
une proposition propane a dit une
compacte beaucoup trop la confiance
amusé de leurs intérêts de leurs maîtres
et les 3 oh my god
on envoie la musique du cadeau sa mairie
de venir faire un petit bisou à
supprimer
sur la bouche avec la langue est-ce
qu'on peut filmer les chaussures est-ce
qu'on peut filmer les chaussures de la
demoiselle est constament elle c'est
incroyable c'est des talons de 1 m bah
écoute et observe tech data du temps le
voilà qu'à l'afrique c'est très très
beau on peut montrer aux gens pas je
crois que c'est une sorte de mouton en
fait plus de ça tu as gagné quatre
places sur le pacte terminée soit a
perdu tellement désolée mais c'est
uniquement
est-ce qu'on peut mettre l'accent sur ce
dérapage et ses portes et quatre places
pour hausser partial pour le pack de sa
géniale
apparemment il ya un membre qui a
disparu oui tout à fait mr vie et n'est
pas là il est aux aînés aux concerts de
maitre gims abuser ça abusé il est une
voix on t'aime plus trop si le
questionnaire street kabylité ok vous
êtes des mecs les mecs du du route ou
pas est-ce que le uss et auprès des gens
comme moi trop en kahn est sorti la
première ermax enjoint aux gens de canal
86 et fort ce que c'est presque ça omagh
à 87 ya une fille sur twitter la et
american qui demande à mettre un peu de
musique avoir tout domoun began to work
et jérémy pied réjouis toi toi toi toi
c'est quoi cette musique à aa
ça va pas
citez-moi trois films de gangsters
américains american gangster attend le
parrain 2 3 alors qu elle a tout à
gagner la gauche ok et encore une
question a pu teint trop bizarre eux
écoutent thibault achète la question
autrement plus tard c'est c'est la bonne
ambiance et la détente
c'est ce qu'on appelle la drogue
quelqu'un est il capable de faire du
break parmi vous
devant tout le monde alors questionné
alors attention du semeur alors c'est un
blind test mais d'une seule chanson
c'est hyper rapide vous êtes prêts à
réagir pour le pentest 3 2 1 c'est parti
et je ne sais plus voir interrogé
on en a un là qui veut répond
asie ici au somail alors c'est le
premier extrait on va dire de le paix
que je vais sortir bientôt très bientôt
depuis pas mal de temps j'essaye de
magazines et de son plein de sons pour
sortir un bel p et voilà on a commencé à
clips et je suis vraiment fier de ce
sont il est très bien reçu par les gens
je suis content que vous le connaissiez
merci l'a pas vu ça me plaisait alors je
sais que parmi le groupe et à un
deuxième chanteur moi je sais pas
forcément la taille décès colette
incroyable musique à la basse et hakim
on peut le dire tu as passé le casting
de la nouvelle star 2008
apparemment battu la rater tu as essayé
franchement c'est pour le geste c'est
beau en plus on van mais franchement on
remet ça pour rigoler en plus sont
vraiment bien alors le bien d'autrui
tant à faire gagner car et membre du big
bang qui n'est pas la question très
difficile
eh oui ilic bon bah voilà
écoute les dés sont lancés
mais je sais qu'il ya un différé de deux
minutes donc du coup on doit attendre la
réponse comme ça prendrait pour cet été
trouvé mais qu'il a trouvé mister vie on
peut l'appeler
qu'est-ce qui va gagner tous les cas si
elle a gagné des places de cinéma pour
mk2 c'est bien non c'est cool
[Musique]
des places de ciné je crois pas que
j'aurais rochelle toi
à temps ces femmes sont très très belle
le challenge est rien à faire original
et des mots sur plateau mariana tant
qu'ils sont pas là non mais on pense
fort à l on leur envoie des bisous et
franchement je pense que si elle avait
pu venir elle elle serait venue avec
joie car tu sais à quel point nous
t'aimons huawei
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
invitation et je vais vous le dire
beaucoup gens m'ont demandé
audrey si vraiment sortis ensemble qui a
dit oui les salons j'ai dit la vérité et
non bien couché ensemble déjà mais je
l'attends là où ne sortent pas ensemble
non on le dit officiellement on le dit
officielle du système ait des chances
pour tous les gars qui sont là les
vraies intentions la dalle mais j'ai eu
la chance quand même de te gifle et à
plaisir senti mal et a éclaté et en fait
on peut en parler puisqu'on est là aussi
pour faire ton live c'est que norman
qu'on appelle nous nono me dis donc tu
me met une claque
je suis dit ok d'accord avec juste un
joli chèque de meuf t'a beaucoup jour
parmi je pense qu'on en fait voilà donc
fait pour moi pas pourquoi pas tant ce
dernier montre plus tôt membres
eh bien ma soeur on peut en parler a pas
qu'une fois elle a eu des barbies j'ai
pleuré que tu le dis tu vois pas ce
qu'un garçon qui assume pas beaucoup de
messages de meuf qui s'en remet aux
étoiles et on change de sujet est ce que
vous gagnez un cadeau a et bien sûr dans
ce cas là on va tourner la fente à
roulettes qui lui rappelle sponsorise ce
live et c'est grâce à eux qu'on peut
offrir des cadeaux totalement géniaux
aux abonnés aux internautes
on tenait non non on en revient au jeu
mais bien mon pote à touba ça veut dire
quoi ça et bien et vient de gagner et
nos playstation 4 coupes un petit peu
voir chez toi tu peux le faire visiter
la voit pas vous voyez bien il ya une
pagaie attend explique nous ton délire
là c'est moi c'est pas un arbitre et pas
madame à mazères moi je sais pas ce
qu'elle va gagner mais tu es bien là
c'est le gros cadeau le boss le truc de
ouf à la gagne et ne put intérêts
[Musique]
regardez tous les types de cas madame
sans gêne l'arrivée sur le dans le game
a quand même temps ça fait deux ans je
pense ces jeunes hommes
en deux ans il a totalement percée dans
plein de films déjà raté deux cibles de
films c'est qu'elles jouissent ils
sortent en septembre ou en octobre
ça s'appelle le correspondant est tamara
d'accord j'ai un petit premiers rôles
voilà voilà
bien sûr tout ce qui est marrant c'est
que quand je t'ai demandé lanta chênes
toi même tu savais pas je ne connais la
stella beau ici voilà c'est pour ça que
je savais pas quoi mais lui c'est un
mytho 1 depuis et tu repars avec une
clio 2 200 km félicitations à ce que
j'invite les gens à s'abonner cette
chaîne ouais j'ai vu qu'ils avaient pas
encore beaucoup des bois non en fait
c'est la première on la porte 4 à voler
ta g nulle part tu vois on a fait la
vidéo a que nous qui l'avons vu les
mi-temps nous c'est un très très bon
choix de locations milk a cependant
parlé il trouve ça bien c'est bien c'est
un conseil a pas de rajeunir l astee l
abbé eux voilà ces deux mondes la chaîne
et vous cherchez l'un portant sur paris
on cherche à l'appartement s'est passé
ça enfin répondent au hashtag trouver un
appart à jimi was his à la 3g une
réponse ces demandes à jawad
ok il ya des savanes et 1 victoire et
c'est ce qui est qui commence à se poser
des questions sur tarn signature à
norman est allé demande de faire dix
font alors allez mon nom et des pelles
ailleurs courte ensemble et la petit qu
un futur mal à à 2 330 le mans et total
600 à chercher qu'on va chercher va
chercher chercher grand mère
[Applaudissements]
incroyable les filles
si vous êtes intéressé fut là c'est vrai
il avait très très peur avant de plonger
la vue de ma mère je ne vais pas moi il
n'avait pas le choix parce qu'ils
avaient pépito notre moniteur de plongée
qui l'a pris par le bras a vraiment bien
ici
comment c'est un peu bizarre ce qu'ils
racontent voilà en tout cas on peut voir
le pouvoir le requin taupe c'est pas des
blagues mais vraiment heureux qu'un oui
bien sûr alors la très jolie slip j'ai
décrit j'ai découvert une phobie aussi
que j'ai mais parlons-en en fait je suis
vraiment cet homme a la phobie de
toucher la phobie de double jeu là c'est
moi qui fais le quatuor a insisté alors
que dans le désert c'est n'importe quoi
et c'est un sarcophage qui te lâche dans
le vide
il ya même pas de toboggans c'est le
vide tout de suite ça c'est mon corps
nul
une coupure aucun cette fraternité ont
ce tchèque avec un scaphandre c'est
quand même où c'est quand même assez
prouve que dans l'eau quand même mon
ventre au sort aussi qui touche kitab
voilà c'est un beau jour assez le fier
car aucun enfin la durée on dirait
plutôt une truite comment tu t'appelles
ah ouais je m'appelle antoine salut à
toi non je vois en toi tu penses qui a
plus de chances norman ou mois pour
tourner la roue tu préfères quelle main
chanceuse je préfère moorman abuser
allez je prendre la main droite pour
parce que c'est la main qui porte chance
3 2 1 c'est parti on te met bien antoine
retrouver sur un put
au mois de mai que de la chance ce mec a
de la chance mais apparemment tu as des
écouteurs il faut donc c'était plus à y
faire
bah oui mais attends je suis reçue par
norman quand même passé quelque chose
toutefois il a écrit qu à la bataille
comme rachid rail mon pote
quelle force quelle musculature force de
frappe peut l'applaudir
laetitia tu es tombé sur force de frappe
ça veut dire qu'à force de frappe du mot
est bien vain de gagner le playstation
store aux réactions merci beaucoup merci
mille fois merci à toi merci à toi tu
est hyper gentil et on a eu la chance
d'avoir des artistes comme christine and
queens comme soprano de charlie winston
les casseurs flotteurs the do louane
voilà que dès que des gens qu'on aime et
des gens très talentueux
c'est vachement bien ouais je parle et
se taper meuf on va vous faire deviner
des à des morceaux avec des instruments
un peu bizarre comme ceux qui couchent
ville vous savez qu'une pile
glockenspiel ah ouais c'est un mot
allemand un mois elle commence comme ça
s'entend qu est ce que tout le monde
appelle un xylophone mais non c'est un
glockenspiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'arabie neige bravo qu'elle était
musical sur le black album 1979 c'est ma
jolie et à béton exactement bravo
[Musique]
la main que là tout s'enchaîne alors
c'est génial
[Musique]
la bonne réponse toi tu peux bien
chanter avec lui tu veux
[Musique]
on va remettre les choses au point
commente andrea on te demande d'être
totalement bilingue
j'ai un bon gros morceau du punk à la
plage je te brosses de revenir dans dix
ans quand tu sera totalement bilingue et
merci d'être venus cheikh du ghetto
c'est bien merci andré acteurs patients
bref c'est un morceau un peu spécial oui
c'est un mashup gasquet mais si vous
savez que c'est un mashup genre dû
s'excuser
attends je veux dire te demander ce que
c'est parce que tu peux tu à malines et
moi je sais pas ce que c'est alors c'est
quoi un mashup et là tu m'as bien calé
parce que c'est totalement ça s'est
souvent les dj qui font ça s'est souvent
les déjections soit comme dj zebra jeu
sexy inna qui connaissent pas dj zebra
allez voir c'est super mais très très
bien ce dj celle de maxime allais il est
très beau ton casque et c'est un tel
accent du sud vient d'où de suisse à
ankara c'est l'accent du sud de la
suisse je m'entraîne et reconnue au sud
de la suisse
et je sais déjà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai traîné là ce genre de jeu alors
même pas eu un seul à des mortes de
morceaux c'est un temps gelé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je connais la musique mais je
connais peu là on ne juge pas on y
perdrait sans vos mélanges et athéna
ch'ti spirit et n'accepte pas dire à
maxime c'est a galéré mais tu as gagné
quand même la gagner quatre places de
ciné vraiment cool on a partagé des
trucs avec tout le monde à discuter
sérieusement on a déconné à délirer les
genres gagner des cadeaux j'espère qu'on
pourra le refaire
j'espère que vous écrivez aussi les gens
du public
j'étais je précise un très très bon
public et donc gérer complices en
musique on sur un petit boeuf
ok je vois ce que tu veux faire
[Musique]
merci youtube merci au public
terre propre char
non mais
mais c'est très simple c'est papa
cigognes qui va dans la nuit deux mamans
cigognes et là il commence un petit peu
bas à faire des bisous ah bon [ __ ]
j'étais persuadé que ça se passait comme
dans la catégorie gang bang sur x hunter
ah ouais